hallo leute heute drehen wir wieder ein
video unserer neuen super easy german
reihe für euch in jedem video stellen
wir euch ein wichtiges deutsches werk
vor heute wird es das werk fahren los
geht's
[Musik]
dresen ich fahre
du fährst er sie es fährt wir fahren sie
fahren möchte motorradfahren er schiebt
das motorrad aus der garage
[Musik]
ali fährt eine testrunde auf der straße
wie sie da wo fährst du hin
ich fahre mit dem fahrrad in die stadt
möchte mitfahren
ich habe keine zeit aber kannst du mir
äpfel vom markt mitbringen ich fahre
dann mal los das klatschen so hoch fährt
nun in die stadt wo wart ihr denn was
ist mit mir
[Musik]
danke mama war doch nicht immer den müll
herum ja doch nicht so aus der haut
fahren mal wieder unter maja möchte
gerne eine runde rollschuhfahren ich
kann leider nicht rollschuh fahren
[Musik]
maja fährt auf dem gehweg
war doch mal vorsichtig maja das perfekt
kann sowohl mit dem werk sein als auch
mit dem werk haben kombiniert werden ich
bin gefahren du bist gefahren er sie es
ist gefahren wir sind gefahren ihr seids
gefahren
sie sind gefahren mit dem fahrrad in die
stadt gefahren ja schön
[Musik]
maja ist gegen das auto gefahren futur 1
ich werde fahren
du wirst fahren er sie es wird fahren
wir werden fahren ihr werdet fahren sie
werden fahren
ali wird nun eine runde motorradfahren
maja wird jetzt nach hause fahren
[Musik]
wir werden morgen in den urlaub fahren
das war unser video über das verfahren
jetzt seid ihr dran um euer deutsch
weiter zu verbessern empfehlen wir euch
unsere app sieht lang auszuprobieren
dort haben wir zum beispiel einen gender
trainer entwickelt der euch dabei hilft
die artikel zu den wichtigsten 2000
deutschen nur zu trainieren
probiert es mal aus und bis bald
[Musik]